[Música]
ah
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
francia en foco hoy desde región es la
capital de la trufa por su calidad en el
corazón de la región de provenza en el
sureste del país estamos en el mercado
de las triunfos próximo a cumplir su
centenario y uno de los más importantes
de europa en esta emisión les contaremos
cómo es que la trufa llega a la mesa y a
la alta gastronomía también les
contaremos cómo es que un perro con un
olfato único es el encargado de cavar
para encontrar este producto y una misa
en honor a todos los triperos
acompáñenos en esta misión de francia en
foco
existen más de 100 especies de trufas
pero una de las más buscadas por su
interés culinario es la trufa negra se
trata de un hongo de lujo buscado por
perros truferos cada día de invierno
volvamos all y vamos no te alejes son
los k acompañamos al guión uno de los
20000 truficultores que existen en
francia y a sus perros adiestrados oli
pidió y trufa a casa de estos diamantes
negros bajo la tierra en un suelo con
idoneidad trufera como el sur del país
se forman entre ellos frecuentemente
entre la hija y la madre y entienden que
hay que hacer agujeros la pequeña no
está muy entrenada todavía
hace un año que empezó y está comenzando
a entender sigue a los demás
con su triunfo como se le conoce a la
nariz del perro buscan la trufa no
importa la raza ni mucho menos los
cruces
aquí hay una bella una grande esta es la
melanosporum el tamaño perfecto es muy
buscada
es la extra como dicen los compradores
los negociantes este equipo de trabajo
puede recolectar de 1 a 2 kilos por día
lo que representa en un mercado al
público hasta unos 2000 dólares según la
demanda y lo hacen entre una hora y
media y 2
son solo compost esta es la recompensa
porque han trabajado muy bien ellos han
encontrado la trufa y hoy hay una
pequeña galleta
y aquí otra a 15 centímetros bajo tierra
con su excepcional olfato unas 100 veces
superior al de los humanos los perros
sienten su aroma a más de 10 metros de
distancia activado en las heladas sólo
la alfa tean pero no se la comen como si
lo hacían los ya casi extintos
buscadores los cerdos o las moscas
es la ventaja de la tierra arenosa que
da frutas redondas sin defectos en medio
de una simbiosis con las raíces de roble
encinas pinos o avellanos crecen estas
preciadas setas pero necesitan de suelos
calizos y lavanda para guardar la
humedad
vamos lo pensamos
el peso del día a mayor peso mayor valor
pero son las más difíciles de encontrar
y su costo varía cada año cuanto da 1,4
kilos estas joyas que ofrece la vida
subterránea y que encuentran los perros
salen de aquí en su estado de maduración
hacia el mercado
el perfume de la famosa tuber
melanosporum la reina de las trufas
impregna dos calles de asia jones
anfitrionas del tradicional mercado
cada sábado de noviembre a marzo se dan
cita a comerciantes truficultores
vecinos de regiones aledañas y turistas
en la avenida de las navas y en la calle
de mistral la primera de venta al
público y la segunda para los
profesionales desde las cajuelas de sus
carros
acompañamos a este mercado al chef
nicola y propietario de uno de los
cuatro restaurantes que hay en gijón
son hermosas son muy firmes bien densas
bien negras excelentes vuestros
productos magníficos
mira esta de aquí
estas están mejor para la presentación
[Música]
y entre el aroma revelador en la compra
la densidad que muestra si está recién
cosechada y el color y las vetas que
definen su variedad lo último en lo que
se piensa es en el precio
el precio no significa nada de hecho con
nicolás eso no se discute sólo se
discute la calidad y el precio es
importante pero en realidad se necesita
tan poco que no es tan caro como creemos
es más barato que la vainilla es más
barato que la vainilla es cierto la
factura llegará al restaurante no hay
intercambio de dinero en el mercado de
los profesionales
por lo que esto como estas para el
restaurante 2
468 debería ser bueno para hoy
cuántos platos puedes preparar con esa
cantidad no las voy a hacer para 35 o 40
personas eso varía también depende de la
fuerza del producto
y de mistral a la rabassa
un último vistazo a lo que ofrece el
mercado antes de ir a la cocina
desde aceites y árboles truferos hasta
cepillos para limpiarlas y mandolinas
para su corte fino si las ponen sobre
tostadas pastas con huevo en una
ensalada siempre en tajadas
y ahora a la preparación y huevos brad a
la trufa por supuesto que junto a la
especialidad del pueblo el omelette a la
trufa es el más buscado
sobre todo los huevos mezclados con la
trufa durante tres días
porque
para que el perfume atraviese la cáscara
y perfume al huevo cool
yo la defino que aquí está terminada no
es un noble de estrellado no debe quedar
duro sino ligero aireada y emocionada su
blog ayer en mención
y con una bella trufa como esta rallamos
aquí el plato para la degustación
y en este cuadernillo de 15 recetas
alrededor de la trufa nicole aquí
comenzó su carrera en parís pero que hoy
vive feliz en gijón se le muestra a su
cliente y amigo la receta de lo que
acaba de preparar una edición en honor a
los 15 años que llevan esta población y
en el mítico restaurante la escapada
cada tercer domingo de enero los
integrantes de la cofradía del diamante
negro y la gastronomía se dan cita en
una mesa para rendirle honor al santo
patrono de los truficultores lo hacen
desde 1952 y tiene diferentes
particularidades una de ellas es la
ofrenda donde no solamente se reciben
monedas y billetes también trufas
cada año muy él se viste del color de la
trufa de agelia jones
un ritual que hace cada uno de los 170
miembros de la cofradía del sur de
francia
vamos todo en orden el traje está muy
bien salimos
pueblo del enclave de los papás
templario del siglo 12 y medieval por
sus calles viejas habitadas sólo por 500
personas se siente el legado de su
historia y el peso de los caballeros de
la hermandad
este es el bastón del gran maestro de la
hermandad del diamante negro y de la
gastronomía
hay una trufa fresca encima y tenemos el
color amarillo por la omelette y el
negro por la trufa
secreto de una omelette de éxito
es la misa más esperada del año aquí se
bendice la trufa las reservas para poder
ingresar a la iglesia comienzan dos
meses antes
te damos gracias señor por haber
escogido nuestras tierras para hacer
crecer esta estrofa están perfumadas
una vez al año te las ofrecemos por
intersección de san antonio el grande
patrón de los truficultores
y el momento por el que muchos llegan
ver la sexta de la ofrenda los
feligreses y miembros de la hermandad
dan trufas negras en todos los tamaños
[Música]
termina la misa y todos esperan la venta
de las trufas con pesa romana se anuncia
lo recogido
28 kilos
[Música]
desde el atrio de la iglesia todos
quieren escuchar los precios y los
gramos
70 gramos 7 por 6 42 así que
43 triunfas 40 euros
40 euros alguien lo pide
y aquí el resultado mil setecientos
cincuenta euros casi dos mil dólares un
poco más del doble de lo que se tenía
presupuestado por la venta de los 2,8
kilos recogidos en la ofrenda dinero que
va como ayuda a la iglesia
y no podemos salir de gijón sin darle un
vistazo a un lugar que no podía faltar
el museo de la trufa
el museo se inauguró en 2008 tras la
restauración del edificio de la época
templaria que hacía parte de la
comandancia templaria que duró unos dos
siglos un museo que muestra todo el
ritual hacia la trufa el producto
estrella en la región un tesoro
gastronómico deseado por pocos y
desconocido para muchos
nos acompaña el señor vieja andré
él es trophy cultor y alcalde de rhys
jones alcalde gracias por acompañarnos
hemos visto toda la tradición y toda la
cultura alrededor de la trufa cuánto le
aporta la región y cuánto le aporta al
país a la producción francés está sobre
30-40 tonelada de trufa cada año cada
invierno la zona del sur es donde
estamos hoy representa 180 85 por ciento
de esa producción y el g20 representa
más o menos un 50 por ciento de la
producción francés que a lo largo del
invierno se intercambió sobre el mercado
que está aquí en el pueblo desconocido
no solamente en francés sino también en
europa sí claro tiene una importancia
porque como el mercado más grande que
tenemos en francia fue la
la fama del pueblo se ha hecho por su
trufa y ya estamos conocidos sobre todo
en francia claro pero también el mundo
entero bueno como este preciado hongo ha
revolucionado la economía este rincón
francés pues mirad en de más de un siglo
se hace este mercado de gente la calidad
de la trufa a da también una razón para
disfrutar del producto y sobre todo amo
guardar la tradición de producción y la
gente siempre están involucrada en la
trufa en lo que representa con su
mercado con su árbol con sus tierras
entonces muy importante para la economía
del pueblo que puede seguir este este
mercado y con su fama y con su placer
digamos de disfrutar del producto aquí
aritz erentxun siempre hemos escuchado
del alto precio de la trufa cómo se fija
ese precio en la zona no impreso digamos
que se fija en la oferta y la demanda si
hay muchos productos oferta en el
mercado pues los precios van más bien
para abajo y si hay poca producción
entonces ya lo precio van para arriba
pero el precio relativo se habla siempre
de un precio al kilo que puede ser entre
y miller o el kilo pero en verdad para
disfrutar de la trufa con una porción de
10 gramos puede comer trufa y entonces
te va a gastar entre 5 y diego para
disfrutar del producto y de que depende
de esa variación del precio entre 500 y
1000 de la oferta sobre todo en un
mercado que está libre la gente trae su
producción a la venta y entonces si la
oferta es importante pues lo preservan
más bien para abajo y si la oferta muy
poca entonces ya lo precio van para
arriba entonces hablamos de un precio
caro pero hablamos siempre de un precio
del kilo que puede ser entre 500 y 1000
dólares pero en realidad con 10 dólares
la gente puede comer trufa y disfrutar
del producto 10 dólares por cuántos
gramos de trufa más o menos de 8 gramos
de trufa que con eso te puede sacar un
plato y disfrutar que tiene el suelo de
regiones para que la trufa sea tan
famosa al otro tiene una pequeña
particularidad digamos de calidad de
suelos sobre todo
a una tierra que bastante negra que se
puede ver los colores en el campo y que
tiene mucho calcar o activo que
necesario y con un ph que está radio del
8 y que corresponda a la z al hongo que
puede venir en buenas condiciones aquí
es una producción estable no la
proyección varía mucho según lo año la
trufa muy caprichosa y le necesita
muchas cosas agua luz sol ya diferente
temporada del año
entonces el año que tenemos más trufa y
años que hay menos
señor p andrew muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos en france 24 de nada mucho
gusto y hasta aquí francia en foco
gracias por acompañarnos siga con
nuestra programación
[Música]